hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to honeymoony Papa's I
would call it I'm gonna go say out of
this teacher who is apparently a raging
alcoholic and if I know my knowledge
correctly that's gonna benefit me on
dates well actually that just means he's
not gonna be a cheap date man are you
sure you're a tool the hell are you I'm
headed to the beach to work in a few
poses oh good you should join me nothing
like a little exercise to melt that
stress away I'm just not feeling it I'll
be there don't think I have anything
else going on don't even get me started
I have like the worst case of yellow
fever ever ever like a yellow that's
like my specialty that's all I ever knew
just trying to relax a little downtime
between classes no can do you oh gee you
know the place your University of
gynecology my favorite University
students who might agree with you some
money points up in me so I won't forget
last name I could have guessed that I
know could I be more Japanese I don't
know could you I didn't even know if you
were Japanese what's your ideal perfect
vacation life everybody guys are like
well I would have to say I like to stay
home and relax we have so much in common
we can't speak really dumb and know
whoever love you want a burger okay
anyway so you want to go on a date
you could argue you really could
considering you're in between classes
and you have like I'll screw the
students they'll be fine on their own
then self education is the best
education anyway I'll just be over here
playing on my phone in the phone game
with probably not best Donna Dave here
we go Rose I know right I am just
amazing okay there's a lot of hearts on
the table this is where the combos come
in you gotta make the hearts fall into
place I didn't do it [ __ ] five fights
I'm an idiot
okay all right
getting somewhere here getting somewhere
oh yes I am not even close to where I
need to be holy hell this is difficult
if you like to passion oh okay I should
have been going for red the whole time
I'm something else to do that I am
something else I don't know if that's
good or bad I don't know if it's greater
greater I am something else I try not to
be like a bunch of douche bags exactly
that's what I've always been saying
about all of politics Turtle Bay Beach
well I guess I could be spy I'm done
with you now you can't tell me what to
do teacher I'll feel tardy
give me something to write on
hello
oh come on just try time it's going to
look so cute try one on there's nothing
here come on I saw it and I immediately
thought of you you're going to love it
no one watching Wow why are you talking
about look you cute
oh stop there's nothing wrong with a
little skin you can't keep all that boob
tears
so you're stuck with it yeah come on
let's go
I am not going anywhere in this I'm
changing back anything you you are one
horny fairy I'm not here to help you
here hey stop boob girl boobs
stop please do me but if I don't stop me
now I'm gonna regret it forever
damn okay sorry
one second let me go change
which one of these most creepy started
drooling a little bit apologize yeah I'm
like that you know yeah what like what
adorable no oh yeah yeah okay
hi Bali how's it going yes it obviously
matters what me a random stranger who
was watching you change earlier just a
little bit ago and eavesdropping on your
conversation it really matters what I
think over everyone else so glad you
glad we're on the same page well my
goodness my dreams are so bizarre that I
really hope not anyway it's possible
how'd you know that I wanted to talk
about things lies and slander you wanna
you want a burger in your face what's
wrong with a burger gonna have to be
weak to enjoy a burger let's go on date
let's go I need to actually wait I need
to put up my personality and where's my
I gotta get talent yeah I got no talent
I got absolutely no talent charisma damn
that would have been that would have
been a thing all right whatever what's
going on a date you me you me it was
gonna be I'm looking forward to it I
don't think this is how real life works
but hey it's all with like you know the
magic of the fair I've been on like
three dates today this is the fourth one
keep picturing myself falling on my butt
but why are you in that outfit at a
skating rink I'm now I'm not questioning
your taste or anything but what's with
your taste
he likes app she likes the movies that
Triple Crown
triple baby oh baby a triple how do I
get that there's some combos with the
music going on here I got to make sure I
get that music she likes me so much yes
cuz I'm so talented right now I want to
stack up this and stack up this red
now let's go for it
ah but I thought that was a special
turns out especially since I gotta get
some sentiment up before these fashion
arts getting my way they're gonna wreck
me they're gonna wreck it
I wouldn't know what to say either I'm
like unbelievably awesome everything
about me is fantastic detection
everything bang bang bang love gun in
your heart oh my I know I know I know I
know
I am very not
this game is oddly fun this games like
really enjoyed it alright this weird
skating we did in formal dresses I love
it in fact it's my favorite things shall
I break my opponent's knees
no okay it's full of lies youyou have
cups of lies is that what that's what
you have it's literally physically
impossible that those are D cups it's
literally physically impossible whatever
fine whatever okay I gotta I gotta go
now
I gotta go I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
eavesdrop on someone else lose sleep my
date was so good at goodbyes and
speaking of that's timeout right after I
eavesdrop on this little lab boy we have
a conversation here hi there
[ __ ] you didn't tell me you were back
in town hey lover just got in a couple
days ago missed you excuses you know
you're supposed to check in with me as
soon as you hit the ground
of course what was I thinking
I'm sorry I mean won't happen again
that's more like it
how have you been my darling staying out
of trouble well I tried that work is
good
never better commentary on the sad
status of my life what's going on girl
any new mischief to share oh where do I
start
hold that thought have a seat I'm gonna
go grab you a drink I want to hear all
about it I'd love to but yeah I've got
an early day tomorrow I just stopped in
for a second uh come on you're not going
to make me sit here and drink all by
myself are you Rachel I'll call you
later this week girls night out all the
way yeah yeah get out of here already
Oh nope alert looks like a total cougar
- wait that you don't think you realize
the gravity of the situation here this
is what separates the men from the boys
you've got to be aggressive that nice
guys [ __ ] isn't gonna cut it
okay meeting you the cute ones are
always hiding
hon do me a favor and help me out with
my empty glass pretty please
what's in it for me I can make it worth
your while sweet all right away ma'am
right away Oh what should we do about
the fact that we're desperately
attracted to each other
I'm more than just a pretty face you
know most gentlemen your age know me as
misty but you can call me Jessie you
should feel honored I only share that
secret with people I like okay so I've
got a question for you if you want a
million dollars how would you spend it
pretty much something you need from me
sweetie you see I make very special
movies for my a youtuber I'm still
waiting to be helped Oh
yeah so my shift just ended I'm pretty
much out the door I think someone else
should be in any minute I'm just looking
to get a cappuccino it only takes
seconds I mean it's more than a second
so are you serious I should have left
over 15 minutes ago okay I'm done Hey
Wow okay okay mmm I love me some
chocolate I'll have a tall glass of
whatever she's serving know what I'm
saying hey let's see considering what
just went down yeah probably a little
pissed off ready to try to get on her
good side open with something safe like
something she probably wants to hear
ridiculous thanks for offering I'm not
sure it would do much good
Oh me as a complete stranger and also
emperor of the world I mean really is a
cup of coffee so much to ask so sorry
that's pretty brave you don't hear that
often enough is that your technique
hitting on girls at the coffee shop sure
that seems like a lot of people's
techniques why wouldn't it be that than
it is I just do whatever the magic okay
what one I know I've never heard you're
welcome I'll tell you what we shot he
caught me in a good mood
I normally don't give in so easily so
consider yourself lucky
okay my name is Lola pleasure if I can
get my caps
time in the next year maybe we can sit
down I want to hear more about how
attractive I am not exactly the thing
for it's sold out nevermind okay I'm
just gonna ever mind motivates yeah the
goals I haven't achieve that's actually
that's sexy exactly to d-cup seems to be
a lot of d-cups going around here I'm
wondering if this is real life
oh wait no it's a video game oh oh it's
Japanese video game see what you say
your main hobbies I'm always trying to
get better at tennis
you should play me oh maybe I will
we'll pick this up later baby says I'm
all out of time for now so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
have helpful dating advice that you want
from me ask your questions to the love
doctor love the plier mark a lover in
the comments down below thank you
everybody for watching and as always I
will see